it's really wrong for our public figures
for our institutions for the president
of the United States and his spokesman
to just openly come out and say yeah we
want as few white people as we can
possibly get we want as few men as we
can possibly get we want as few people
who follow a traditional sexual ethic as
we can possibly get that's wrong that's
very bad it's a bad thing and we should
we should say it we should not be afraid
to say it for fear of being called
racist or sexist or thisist or phobic or
whatever all the nonsense terms they use
who cares who cares what those people
think who cares what the left calls us
it isn't true first of all isn't true
that we don't like black people isn't
true we don't like women it isn't it
isn't true even if you view
homosexuality with moral program it
isn't even true that you don't like
those people so who cares what the libs
say about you I certainly don't it's
certainly it's very freeing not to care
about that